Hello world. Welcome to sora geology.
Let's talk about four reasons.
Alphago is a huge deal.
Alphago is an AI created by a team of
researchers at Google designed to play the
ancient Chinese game of
go and go to players,
take turns placing black or white
stones on a board trying to capture the
opponents stones or surround empty
space to make points of territory.
The first reason is that it beat the
best human player in the world at a game
that is orders of magnitude
more complex than chess.
Think of solving chess like painting,
align and solving go like painting the
Mona Lisa one is just way more complex
than the other.
Remember Ibm's deep blue and when it beat
world champion Garry Kasparov at chess
in the 90s at the time that was a huge
deal because no program had ever done
that before.
What deep blue did was they would
examine all possible moves and all the
possible countermoves and all the possible
counter counter moves and so on until
it had searched every single possible
play and then pick the best one.
This is called a brute
force search and it worked,
but that method wouldn't
work for go because in go
there are more possible plays
and there are atoms in the
universe. Crazy, right?
So Alphago can't just
try all possible plays.
It has to use intuition like human players
would what it felt would likely be a
good play to do this.
Alphago uses something called a neural
network and neural network is an
algorithm that tries to mimic
how the brain works. Roughly.
You have a bunch of neurons that are
connected to each other a layers.
You have an input layer,
middle layers and an output layer.
Each neuron performed some
preset calculation on the
data and outputs the result
to all the connected neurons.
This process continues until the data
goes all the way from the input layer to
the output layer.
So if you input photos of Trump,
which really just breaks down
to a bunch of ones and Zeros,
if you think about it like all data
and feed it into the input layer,
what it's doing is recording
commonalities across all the photos.
This is called training
and machine learning.
So given enough Trump photos of
eventually it can start recognizing Trump.
When it sees a novel photo, I'll putting
data that means yes, this is Trump or no,
this is not Trump.
The team created a neural network and
input 30 million expert moves from go
until it could output yes is
an expert move, but it's side.
Then they had to play against itself
countless times until it got better and
better through trial and error. This is
called reinforcement learning. We do too.
Whenever we practice shooting
hoops or playing an instrument,
practice makes perfect.
This gave Alphago a sense of
reflection when evaluating a move,
it could look back on simulated results,
but they also wanted to give
it a sense of intuition.
So they created another neural network
that observed the moves from the
simulations. So by combining
these two networks together,
Alphago was able to give an estimate of
how good a move is by using a mixture of
reflection and intuition.
So in a live game,
every turn Alphago uses this
move evaluator on a bunch
of possible moves before
deciding on the best one and playing it.
It's not a full on brute force search,
but a more educated and smaller search.
It's called a Monte Carlo tree search.
So cool.
The second reason is that this took
one year instead of 10 years to build
leading AI experts predict that it
would take a decade to build a machine
capable of beating the best human
player at go. It only took one year.
It's just another sign of the
exponential progress of technology.
Think of all the trends in
computing that this upholds.
Moore's law states that computing
power will double every two years.
The law of accelerating returns by
director of engineering at Google,
Ray Kurzweil states that technological
progress in general is exponential,
not linear.
80% of the world's data was created in
the last year and we are all building and
creating all of each other's
data at an exponential rate.
The third reason is that
this creates a new field.
Ai Psychology in the second game against
least cdot Alpha played a move that no
human would ever play. Move 37 that
move represents the promise of Ai.
When Alpha go played at Lisa Dole
was completely baffled fan way.
The other go master said
it's not a huge move.
I've never seen a human play this
move before and later kept calling it
beautiful,
so beautiful Alphago things differently
than the best of our species at this
task. Even the creators don't
understand how it happened.
That's the beauty of machine learning.
Programmers don't code every single rule
to give it the building blocks to learn
by itself and unleash it
on massive amounts of data.
We can study Alphago and
learn new ways of thinking.
The fourth reason is that this technology
hasn't yet been applied to other
fields. Think about the recent
breakthroughs in quantum computing.
Google proved first of all that a quantum
computer was possible and second of
all,
that it's solved a specific algorithm
100 million times faster than a classical
computer.
Now think of how smart Alphago would
be if it ran on a quantum computer.
Robotics, genetics, physics,
climatology, economics.
This is just the beginning of new
breakthrough discoveries in these fields.
Scientists have tons of data that
no human could possibly sit through.
Certain probably has a new
particle somewhere in its data set.
We just don't have the
intelligence necessary to sift
through the noise and find
the meaningful bits.
Alphago and the promise of Ai is going
to help us solve some of the world's
biggest problems, and we should all
keep a very close eye on this space.
For more information about
half ago or AI in general,
check out the links in the description
below, and as always, thanks for watching.